ヒカキンさん
だけ
見えてるドッキーこんにちははじめ社長です今日はヒカキンさんに不思議な体験をして
もらおうと思いますね今からですね
ヒカキンさんがうーむ我々の上昇夫婦に来るんですけども
さあの案件の説明というかミーティングみたいですが今から行われるんですけどもう
ミーティング2昼休憩でその後
さて僕の言いに来るんですけども虚人さんの今日5月の動き土の中てヒカキンさんに
しか見えてない人がいるようにします
僕もだしあらゆる人は見えてないんですけどもヒカキンさんだけ見えてる人が毎回い
ます
どうなるんだろうなぁなんか心霊的な感覚に襲われるか下手だと思ってきた銀さんが
笑い転げちゃうか
いろんなパターンを予算で言うと思うんですけどもまぁ俺たちは見えてないに俺も見え
てないんだ誰も見えてないんです筧さんだけ見えているので彼が今までに経験したこと
のないような不思議な体験
お見せしましょう
あ一応言ってもらいましたまずは会議室ですね見てくださいこの
無礼な人僕が指示したんですけどこの人はもうちょっと出てるんですけど今の人には誰
も見てない体で今から ax の案件の解禁が始まります日か銀座がこの付の上で寝て
いる女性を見てます何を想うのか最初の見所ですね大駅んぞするとならんかな
なやつなって起こりそうな心配があります
ありえないんだよなぁこの状態は
きた
やばいきたってました今
あーん
[音楽]
何とも言えない感じで今対立でありました
ん
た人がせーん
それ
読んで気歩いていたがいざは十分をしてますね
何も気にせず
次にされましたね
[音楽]
ある違う
アリパイさを探してますわー
させが早速資料に目を通しているんでしょうか気にせずも仕事もとになってますねこの
馬場会議言ってるんじゃないかな普通に
私も行っています
[音楽]
古瀬
だからぁ供与先が打ち上がります
癒し大佐に web 特価なぁ
ban
いやまん k 頑張りましょうやっぱりですよねー
[音楽]
あっよろしくねパワーでてくれます
ある
[拍手]
クッパディーエヌエー
ています
入ってと言ったんだ
初産そうですね
チームすなるので今私が集まりますねそうちょっと現段話させるはキャンプ
[音楽]
ません
綺麗ですね綺麗ですねぷっ
はええええええ
一方疲れからたがるん
いいねぇ
本日よろしくお願いします塗装前に代えさせていただきますね今回はもって感じ釣行記
書入門で同席しておりますのでこちらでよろしくお願いします
はい
宜しくお願いします
[音楽]
us 今回プロモーションを紹介
パーティが痛いのかブーバーし
[音楽]
ブーブー一間
eye-fi と名前だしたに思っている製品だから方あさあダントツ1位こちらに
関しては
大麻
数年間のとかに当たっても低級特に今
とか
いけない方が多いのでを遠隔ワープ
3番ハウン
えっあの子は
dende me
4はています
ありがとうござい人
前回ですこっと
ます
まず一つ目があーん
tt て帰っている使い方やが迫るはあるんですけど
お願いしまーす
こういうことって結構あるん
香りになっています
[音楽]
はいそれじゃさあ
頑張りましょうそう
ブーベロさあしますか
いいですよそれを吐いた
のでございますどうぞえっ
介護やせ
余罪日やお願いしてません今日ほど
はい
あってくれへん
食べました全3種
ございましたーーー
[音楽]
方をだと思う
の方に入れていただけるん
あ
[音楽]
右てるじゃこっち大
影響カシージャなんかいて a
ボーマスメット目してこれ
血が出たのでいいの
[音楽]
いただきます
おいしいおいしい
ございました
[音楽]
me
ありません
re ん
[音楽]
ん
入ってくださいん
[音楽]
ブー
よっしゃーだけど笑っちゃうわー爆睡ますけど多分まだ気付いてないんですね
菅野違和感は覚えているものの中すごい
合わせてくれたみたいで何よりです写真撮ってる
めっちゃさせにとっているのはい
というわけでこの&ご飯を食べた後に偽の比較の ax の撮影でぼくんちに行くん
ですけども僕の家にも
いますよでわっ
[音楽]
ああああああ
うんというこれをカメラがねそれを持ってたんや
ちょっとこういうことがここ
御苦労が軟調4入っていません
あっああぁああまあさっきなんですよって
切ってこっちは変数メアド8賃金の楽しいなあ
加重をかけるとか
保全で1秒台を購入でしまう
を
ここでいても編集してますよ
この人だったらいいですよこの人だったりも全然4を
生活動画ておりますか
夏が来2足の部屋ぬ
[音楽]
大
もう
tee
シュッ
貴重ですよ
この付そっちから移行するねー
全然別だカメラ乗っていますねいい
[音楽]
というわけで
鍵さんだけ人が見える
なげえそうですさあ者
もうねぇどうしてないのでっテロと後輩になるというよ俺はなんか
あとも保守派からくらいおかしい感じたちでしたよ
今回の攻略第二なったのがですね職人さん見えてるんですけどもほかの人が見えてない
ということで
八木さん
人って
見えない部分が大事なんです見えない匂いとかそういう部分に気を使うのがパス的な
男性の1本なんじゃないかなと思いますよねそれをもういいよってなったら親父や
ねそうねそこ捨てちゃいけない入ってきた銀さん転んで外出する機会が少なくなって
いると思うんですけどもう人と会うためだけじゃなくて室内で使ってもいいと思うん
ですよの香り
まあ確かにねだって言え流れどう自分が気分よくなるかとか癒される方に大事だからな
自分点がニッシュってやって自分か良い香りするだけどすごいて仕上がると思うんだ
けど使い方もアリだと思いますそしてアップさですねボディースプレーだけではなくて
ボディー総武などもありますそしてですね
今話題の no l ぐらいとさんとの書き下ろし楽曲も公開される
いるみたいでキャンペーンを実施されてみたいです
[音楽]
ん
ぐうっずっとステラといえばですね ax と脳いるブライトのライブチケットが
当たるコラボキャンペーンを実施中です負けです皆さん概要欄でチェックしてみて
くださいというわけで
をヤフーは今日のこの動画をとして見えない部分の大切だかなと思いますのでソース
確かにちょっとオヤジ化してくるって言って処分の舞期間 today
仮とやろうかなと思いたいあんまり考えたことなかったで見えないところの見えなるん
だよ
お家でもぜひより楽しみてくださいばいばーい
うわぁ
あっは
[音楽]
blr